well sometimes truth really is Stranger
Than Fiction this is going to be hard
for many of you to believe but the
transformation of Alan dershowitz seems
almost complete he is now representing
my pillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell
now when I say transformation in the
interview we're going to look at shortly
dershowitz says he's still a liberal
Democrat who voted for Biden but that
he's getting involved in these cases
because of the principles the legal
principles Etc
it is a cartoonish mess
that pillow is
and then you add dershowitz to it and it
is just some kind of very strange uh uh
salad of some kind I don't even know
what words to apply to it here is
dershowitz saying he is going to ask for
a special Master for the pillow cell
phone it's every single one of these
things couldn't be a bigger joke
remember that Mike pillow's phone was
seized by the FBI at a Hardy's
drive-through not long ago and here is
pillow interviewing his new lawyer Alan
dershowitz issue The subpoena for the
telephone so that they could get in
search the telephone completely and what
we're seeking is what the president
Trump got in the Mar-A-Lago case the
appointment of a special investigator to
look into this or return of the cell
phone because the the search was a
general search the kind of General
search that the framers of our
constitution
um wanted to specifically Outlaw in the
Fourth Amendment now dershowitz is a
lawyer and so are Trump's lawyers Alina
Haba and Christina Bob and all those
people they made the same argument after
the search warrant was executed at
Mar-A-Lago they said this was a fishing
Expedition it was General they sort of
took everything there was no discretion
this is unconstitutional and then of
course it didn't actually turn out that
any judge or Court agreed with them here
is an interview on the law and crime
Network wherein Alan dershowitz explains
why are you working for Mike pillow
now the answer might be because Mike
pillow has a lot of money that might be
the real answer I don't know but take a
listen to some of this well thank you
first of all let me tell you why I'm
representing Mike Lindell I agree with
him about very little I think the
election was fair I think he's wrong in
challenging uh the election we're on
completely different sides I'm a liberal
Democrat I voted for Biden he's a
Conservative Republican I think it's as
critically important for people on my
side of the political fence people who
are Biden supporters supporters of the
election to hold the justice department
accountable for trying to Target our
political enemies I think the criticism
should come from within our party not
only outside the party so I'm very
anxious to defend the constitution on
behalf of Michael Lindell the search
itself was clearly a general search okay
and then he makes the same point we
heard him make in the earlier segment
now listen here's the story with this
if
how can I say this
the fact that it took this long
for there to be any action given Trump's
consistent wrongdoing year after year
after year tells us that if there were
really
any
biased interest
in how this went down
it's that the FBI and doj were too
reluctant to get involved in going after
Trump
so what pillow and Trump and dershowitz
want us to believe is the fact that
these things happened at all that there
was the raid on Mar-A-Lago that there
was the seizure of pillow's cell phone
the fact that these things happened at
all is indicative of political bias and
attempts at political retribution
there has been so much wrong doing that
the way I see it is the fact that it
took this long suggests they were really
reluctant and they wanted to be really
careful and really sure and of course
all the evidence we have points that way
when you look at
the search warrant for the uh for the
Mar-A-Lago when you look at the fact
that the Attorney General signed off the
FBI director signed off a judge signed
off everything was made just so
and it didn't really matter that the
Trump is because they still said it was
illegal it's a political Witch Hunt all
these different things they'll say that
either way
but so far no court has found that any
of those arguments have Merit my
expectation
is that courts will similarly find that
dershowitz's arguments about the pillow
phone seizure
pillow phone seizure those are the terms
we're using we'll also be without Merit
that's my expectation we will watch and
we will see
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
One-Stop shop for healthy easy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
delivered right to your door with fresh
organic baby food for every stage
toddler and kids meals that even the
picky eaters will love and the new line
of healthy smoothies little spoon has
you covered little spoon makes
everything fresh it's just like homemade
it's ready in mere moments all of the
recipes are delicious they're
nutritionally balanced and free of junk
little spoons baby food is 100 organic
and cold pressed for every eating stage
for toddlers and kids little spoon has
the classics mac and cheese but they'll
sneak things in like butternut squash
and carrots they have more adventurous
meals cheesy pupusas or chicken pot
stickers they're all kid approved packed
with nutrients and little spoons organic
smoothies are perfect perfect when you
need something quick and easy and the
best part is kids meals under six
dollars and baby food and smoothies
under three dollars each plus you'll get
fifty percent off your first order when
you go to littlespoon.com and use the
coupon code Pacman 50. the link is down
below